I was on a hike literally yesterday and
I got stopped by these two two dudes
that were like oh hey you look like
Glenn I was like yeah I I was on the
show and then they go hey did they kill
you off or like did you want to leave
and they gave me like two options of
like did they force you out or did you
want to leave and I was like
it's not like that like and and I was
with my children and they were like
really trying to get to the meat of like
was I pushed out or not and for me I'm
like I don't have time to explain this
to you first off because I have two
children we gotta go home it's
sweltering it's a hike but also I was
trying I was trying to I didn't know how
to succinctly say like
sometimes you just accept what it is and
you just go with it like there's no
tension behind right any of those things
like when someone presents to you after
five six seasons on a show and they go
hey looks like this is the end for you
and also with the added like bonus of me
having a comic book issue come out two
years prior that says I'm done right you
you go like okay like am I scared am I
kind of worried about what's coming like
perhaps but also okay like that's just
what that is like I'm not gonna go like
Kicking and Screaming it's also to the
point of what you brought up before
which is you can't bring it with you
um you made this I don't know if it was
a conscious decision but somehow you
knew okay I'm leaving this experience
and I'm not going to try and replicate
it duplicate it I'm not going to try and
find this someplace else and keep it
going it's time to change it up yeah and
I don't even know if it's that conscious
I just think it's like manifest for me
as like
my police voice in my head says
if you do it again you're a hack
and so I just
don't do it again I can't I I cringe at
the at for me personally right also it's
not like your character could have come
back
they made it so clear the the way in
which you departed that show was so
unbelievably brutal one of the most
shocking things I've seen on television
and yeah I'm including my own early work
in 93-94 so good uh but no but like but
I was just I I you know it's not like
Glenn could come back and go I've got a
terrible headache yeah and my eyes
knocked out but I think I'm okay yeah
yeah and that's it too like those are
the those are the blessings that I feel
like I've gotten in my life which is
like an absolute door shut yep like
there's not like there's not like a
crack in the door it's like this is slam
shut and it's like barricaded you can't
come back in what are you gonna do you
know like petition outside the door like
they're not gonna open it I have to say
because you and I uh have been friend
and know each other and I really like
you I got I will admit
um the actor who plays Negan who killed
you with the baseball bat yeah Jeffrey
Dean Morgan yeah Jeffrey Morgan he came
on our shows at Comic-Con
and I swear to God it took it was an
effort for me to not have attitude
only aging adults who understand who's
in Show Business and understands I had a
little bit of trouble like you [ __ ] I
feel so bad my friend and uh it was just
it was in there a little bit I think I
cut him off a few times on his anecdotes
or I read the notes and read the head to
what joke he was gonna do and got there
first yeah yeah and more like a
grapefruit right what well that's all
the time we have for this [ __ ]
murderer
all right once you get your bat and get
the [ __ ] out of here oh God friend
killer he had such a hard gig to like
show up displace the foundation of the
show and then like continue on yeah and
then stick around yeah like be there now
let's show the lighter side of Negan
yeah um Wild